for price it'll be his sixth start of
the year the first couple of those
starts were more of an opener roll he's
legit a starting pitcher now though he's
got a 2-0-3 era in that role after he
gave up just one run in four innings
against these rockies over the weekend
last start with no decision and it was a
solid one so i looked for david to
really continue to grow with his pitch
count but also his ability on the mound
since coming back off the il
combination of being an opener starter
he's three and oh two holds and a 2-1-6
so he is really starting to find it
price comes home and off we go with a
bouncing ball to zach mckinstry one
pitch and one out to open this one
alexander chichi gonzalez who gave up
seven runs in four innings against the
dodgers last friday and that 599 era now
the worst in the national league so
the recipe is right for the dodgers to
get right it would seem tonight pitch to
taylor he swings and drives it to the
left field corner that's going to bounce
a couple of times and go to the wall
taylor around first and he's on his way
to second with a first pitch stand up
lead off double double number 17 for
chris taylor and the dodgers are in
business early taylor has done a great
job filling in for mookie bets in the
lead off spot in his second game in a
dodgy uniform it's billy mckinney
grounds on right side at least moves the
runner up race to the bag gonzalez there
first put a productive out from mckinney
taylor the third one gone and home of
the one-two to turner
foul ground first base side krone has
room
taylor goes halfway down the line and
now back to the back and now it'll be up
to will smith to see if he can get home
the first run of the game taylor third
two gone one-one pitch
smith lines above the left-center field
and they take advantage of the lead off
double
smith with a double of his own his major
league leading 13th run bad at into the
second half
dodgers one rocky's nothing
that's 11 hits in 23 advance for smith
against colorado cody ballinger who had
a base hit against chichi gonzalez in
his first stat bat of the second half
2-2
bellinger ropes on the right field
that's going to get down for a base hit
blackman will backhand it over toward
the line rounding third as smith he is
in to score and sliding in safely with a
pop-up slide and an rbi is cody
bellinger and it's two-nothing dodgers
that's gotta feel so good for cody the
dodger fans are enjoying it a breaking
ball near the middle of the plate and
you see the second tool there's the
reason that you can be patient with cody
and getting back the speed we've seen
the speed and the glove and the arm and
center field now the bat may be coming
alive three straight two out base
runners getting made into the plate in
the first inning
sends one the other way tapia won't get
it villains are in the score the dodgers
put up three in the
[Music]
they had the first right they just
didn't hit it with the exit velocity to
get it to tapia
albert is having so much fun on the
dodger uniform a 30 pitch inning for
gonzalez mckinstry a 236 hitter seven
home runs on the season and his very
first one came against the rockies
on opening day was an inside the park
one swings and misses here and strikes
out but the dodgers strike for three
runs elias has the average at 211 with
seven home runs and 18 rbis
one-two pitch is hit high in the air
left field moving back is pollock at the
wall and that is over and out of here
home run elias diaz his eighth and the
rockies are on the scoreboard they trail
three to one the first two months of the
season he hit 125 but he has been hot
lately his average over the last 15
games or so is hovering around 350.
chi-chi was able to get justin turner on
a foul out to cj crone off the first
base bag turtle sends one in the air
deep left center back to the wall it's
gone lead off home run justin turner
partying like it's 2005 taking chi-chi
gonzales deep we talk about expectations
justin turner this year
has met them and surpassed them
thrown at first blackman at second and
the batter is the left-handed hitting
ryan mcmahon
pitch a ground ball to second mckinstry
flips to taylor one on the first that's
a double play
the twin kill helps out david price and
cleans up the unit no runs two hits
no errors and a man left after three and
a half it's the dodgers four colorado
one
pitch is swung on and lined good sliding
backhand stab by krone gets up flips to
gonzales to get mckinstry at first good
play on both ends as gonzalez points to
cj crone able to flag that one down
well a lot of overspin cj went down and
then the ball took a big bounce because
of the spin but a nice job by the big
man tonight
four k's
no walks
only three hits trevor swings he got a
good swing there did he get all of it he
did touch him all time trevor's story
with a home run to dead center field and
that makes it a 4-2 dodger lee you know
you're strong when the center fielder
gives the courtesy job came right over
the plate
right into the hot zone trevor timed up
that fastball is 12th homer of the year
and now bickford will have to face the
left-handed hitting ryan mcmahon 2-1 to
mcmahon
is hit through the hole on the right
side for a base hit mckinney up with the
ball blackman around third he scores
krone on his way to third ryan mcmahon
an rbi single it's now a 4-3 dodgers
lead
pickford's 0-2 pitch
swung out of his strike threes cracks
out diaz gives up two hits rockies will
leave two on base on two to bellingers
he's missed on two high fastballs we'll
see where they go here on the o2 pitch
outside target set ballinger hammers it
deep right center field
this one back and this one is off the
very top of the wall bellinger running
out of the box he's around second on his
way to third with a stand-up triple
oh cody ballinger with his second hit of
the ball game this one missing going out
of the yard by inches and obviously a
big run at third in the one run game
here first one from bowdoin
is rifled into left field
[Applause]
now it's blackman 0-2 charlie hits it
towards left and that's going to be a
fair ball
cutting it off in the corner mckinstry
overruns it and that'll allow hampson to
score all the way from first an rbi
double charlie blackman makes it a 5-4
dodger lead tying ron blackman at second
with two outs here in the eighth
and a hard hit ball through the right
side ryan does it again blackman cuts
the bag and the throw will not be nearly
in time the rockies all leaving with the
dodgers in l.a sam hilliard set up as a
pinch hitter here in the pitcher's spot
1-2 pitch is well hit the right field if
it stays fair it is gone sam hilliard
touch him all time
five rockies single single walk to load
them up for the longest tenured dodger
position player
and it's in the dirt close to the back
stop here comes the tire
six to six single single walk walk
strikeout strikeout swag in a miss he
got him oh my goodness
somehow some way we're going to extra
innings 2-1 pitch to trevor is lined
fair into left field for a base hit
hampson gets the green light coming home
the throw off the mark hampson slides in
story down to second and the rockies get
the lead and here's charlie blackmon
nobody out in the 10th two on to charlie
charlie crushes his ball deep right
center take a good look you won't see it
for long blackman does it to the dodgers
again and the rockies build the lead to
9-6 in the 10th
barnes hard shot right at fuentes across
the diamond ball game over what a
victory for the colorado rockies